I remember first hearing about it from
my uncle Peter who lives in Long Beach
and when I visited him in LA for the
first time he told me about this
religion that had been created by a
sci-fi writer called l ron Hubbard and
then it was beloved of actors and
celebrities and that they used hard
sales tactics these are all his
allegations I mean I'm sure Scientology
would denied it but and that they that
they were very secret no one really knew
what was going on inside and in fact um
he told me I remember him saying that if
you go down and look at their base
they've got walls around it with spikes
on but the spikes don't face outward the
spikes face inward and I thought one of
this was sort of really appealing I mean
my own my own sense of both the absurd
but also the macabre was massively
piqued Scientology to me seems to be at
a kind of junction of so many
quintessentially American qualities you
know you've got the celebrity dimension
you've got the fact that it's in
Hollywood you've got it so the relation
to the business world and this
swashbuckling form of capitalism that we
have in the u.s. where you find a need
and you market to it and if the need
doesn't exist then you create the need
to mediate some it's always very telling
when you realize that basically
mcdonald's and scientology came into
existence almost exactly the same time
around about 1950 Dianetics was
published and the first McDonald's was
established and and actually as business
models they're rather similar in they
both work using branch a franchise
system and in a sense to me scientology
is selling spiritual hamburgers if you
like this is piquant see that's added to
it because of the strangeness and humor
that's wrapped around it you know the
bizarreness of the language and the
ritual the packaging
is to be quite funny in the heart of
Scientology is a kind of contradiction
which is that they want to spread the
good news about Scientology and
Dianetics it's a life-changing
life-saving system that allows you to be
your best and in fact more than that is
our last best hope for saving the planet
from war insanity crime intolerance and
so forth but they also don't want to
give up those secrets too easily because
in fact well either because they would
say you have to go through a certain
path and that takes us an orderly step
and you have to sort of pay your way
through to the path which is a bridge to
total freedom as they call it
but but actually arguably it's because
it's at this their business model to
sell secrets so the contradiction is
well how do you market a secret right
and and unlike you know other religions
that I can think of Christianity right
it you can get a Bible in any hotel room
you'll find one in the top drawer of
your bedside table and Islam Buddhism
Hinduism all the major religions as far
as I'm aware they're sacred texts are
freely available and there aren't as
there aren't a whole bunch of Secrets
you know origin stories or mysterious
myths that you have to pay to learn well
what's inside the box you know what
could it be and they also they also
regard outsiders and in particular
journalists as enemies and so I you know
to me it's actually or both it you know
it's a problem in as much as they're not
giving access but it's also massively
appealing and tantalizing to be
aggressively confronted and turned away
unlike most religions that that you know
that you think of as being sort of
welcoming
and ethical and in the normal way they
sort of invite you come on in film with
us will tell you what we do
Scientology's is constantly it seems to
be kind of pushing you away and telling
you that they don't want your coverage
you know that nothing you can say about
them is going to be the truth
[Music]